you're going to have a chance to shape
the american economy's future if you're
going to the polls in november
that's because your two choices for
president donald trump and former vice
president joe biden
have much different visions about the
path to prosperity
mr trump wants to double down on tax
cuts and deregulation
our movement is pro-jobs pro-worker
pro-police and 100 pro-american
joe biden has a different view he says
he wants to raise taxes on high earners
and also restore relationships with
economic allies
awful lot of hard work and people bust
their neck all they ask for is a shot
either one of them also has to manage
the country's attempt to rebound
from its sharpest economic contraction
on record
here's how the two men stack up on
economic policy
the president and former vice president
are most far apart on taxes
while they both say they won't raise tax
rates for middle-income
households joe biden does want to raise
taxes from the wealthy
the tax policy center says the top one
percent of households would see their
after tax income dropped
17 percent under mr biden's plan
but workers on the low end of the pay
scale could see new tax credits under mr
biden's plan
and that could lessen their burden we
don't need a tax code
that rewards wealth more than it rewards
work
and for president trump the approach is
less is more
his 2017 tax cuts for now are set to
expire in 2025.
if he's reelected president trump says
he wants to make them permanent
the president has also ordered the
treasury department to defer a
collection of social security taxes this
year
if he's reelected he wants to make those
deferrals permanent too
no matter who wins this election the u.s
is in a new era of economic tension with
china
but the similarities on trade between
biden and trump
and there president trump imposed
tariffs on goods imported from china
they ranged from seven and a half
percent to 25 percent
on more than 350 billion dollars worth
of products that americans consume
president trump reached a ceasefire with
china earlier this year
ultimately it's a great deal for both
countries and it's going to also lead to
even a more stable piece
throughout the world the coronavirus has
added a new
chill to the bond between the world's
two largest economies
it's going to make it hard to reach new
deals with america's big
economic rival the united states wants
an open and constructive relationship
with china but achieving that
relationship
requires us to vigorously defend our
national interests
mr trump has also challenged american
allies like canada
mexico and germany biden won't move fast
to take those
china tariffs away but he does want to
repair alliances with other countries
last week i shared the outlines of my
plan to
build back better that plan rejects
the defeatist view that automation and
globalization
mean we can't ensure our future is made
in america on energy in the environment
the incumbent and his challenger are
also worlds apart
and that reflects a much different set
of concerns within their own parties
during his first term president trump
pulled out of the paris agreement to
reduce emissions and combat climate
change
instead the president has prioritized
domestic fuel production
and sped up approvals of new pipelines
and other energy infrastructure
his policies are meant to support jobs
in energy producing regions like the
appalachians
in west texas police is hurt by the
recent recession
we are telling the washington
politicians trying to abolish american
energy
don't mess with texas
if re-elected the president wants to
roll back regulations further
biden on the other hand wants to rejoin
the paris agreement
and make new commitments to reduce u.s
carbon emissions
that includes regulations to cut
commercial building emissions by 2030.
biden also has a two trillion dollar
spending plan to invest in areas like
solar
and wind power
when it comes to government spending if
you look at joe biden's plans or donald
trump's track record
you come out with the same conclusion
it's go big
or go home the biden plan would result
in 5.4 trillion dollars of additional
spending over 10
years that's a fraction of the amount
the progressive wing of the democratic
party wanted
but it's still twice as large as what
hillary clinton proposed in 2016.
biden's platform calls for increases in
spending on education
infrastructure and housing in addition
to the environment
i truly believe we have a tremendous
opportunity to turn this moment of
crisis into a moment of progress
these spending priorities aren't unusual
for a democrat but conservative
republicans might need to make peace
with mr trump's own spending habits
under his leadership federal spending
jumped 15 percent in his first three
years in office
a lot of that was on defense but not all
of it and that was before the
coronavirus crisis
this year spending is projected to go to
6.6
trillion dollars that's more than double
the level of federal spending in
with new taxes federal revenues haven't
kept pace with the bills coming due
under president trump
the government has been funding those
revenue shortfalls with more
and more debt additional government
borrowing in president trump's first
term
is set to exceed six and a half trillion
dollars
that's as much money as the us borrowed
between its founding in 1789
and the recession of 2008 under
either candidate there's simply no end
in sight but there's good news
because interest rates are so low it's
actually very cheap to borrow at this
moment
those interest rates and other
government financial policies
are managed by this institution the
federal reserve and one of the most
important relationships that any
president has
is with the fed's chair among 12
fed decision makers the president
appoints the chair and six other
governors
their powers are vast especially in
times of emergency
during crises the fed lends money to
make sure banks and markets don't
collapse
president trump appointed jerome powell
to be fed chair
then the president criticized the fed
leader for not holding interest rates
down to promote growth
there's negative interest who ever heard
of such a thing
give me some of that give me some of
that money i want some of that money
our federal reserve doesn't let us do it
if trump wins
he'll have to decide whether to give
powell another term starting in 2022.
we need to stay in our lane we do have
this grant of independence i think to
keep that
we need to stay with what you've given
us to do which is maximum employment
stable prices
supervise the banks mr powell did move
aggressively to cushing the economy
during the coronavirus crisis
and that won praise from president trump
but the fed chair has also asserted his
independence from a president who
greatly values loyalty
biden will have the same choice to make
about giving powell another term
if he's elected president obama and
president clinton
both democrats each re-upped republican
chairman for the
job after they became president in the
name of stability for markets and the
economy
would mr biden follow their lead and
which of these choices is best for your
own economic interests
you've got until november 3rd to decide